one
thank you for having me uh i'm ananya
i'm in the learning and games program
and i'm currently a postdoc at ut austin
and i'm going to talk about my work on
the theoretical aspects of cairns
um so we so my work is
primarily statistical um but i'm
interested to be a part of this program
to learn the other side
of the story so what we did was what we
wanted to understand theoretical
guarantees for gans which are
notoriously hard
hard to get um and we wanted to do this
purely from a statistical standpoint so
we looked at the
we wanted to look at this through the
lens of non-parametric density
estimation um we wanted to get
guarantees for gans and what we ended up
having was that we extended the
framework of classical non-parametric
density estimation to these losses that
you get from gan discriminators
and we ended up generalizing this entire
framework of density estimation so just
a quick review i'm sure that everyone is
familiar with this density estimation is
simply the problem
of estimating a specific distribution
from its samples
and so in
in short our contributions were that we
generalized this entire framework to new
losses that you can think uh come from
can discriminators we call them best of
ipms or integral probability metrics and
we were able to unify a lot of previous
works in in this
classical
area
using this framework
and then we were able to prove new
minimax states under these losses and
showed that you can somewhat
alleviate the curse of dimensionality
which just means that usually you need
exponentially many samples um to
estimate a density well um but if you
assume that the loss is weak enough then
you you can alleviate this
this dependence on the dimension a
little bit
um so we showed that there are some
regimes in which many classical
estimators such as the kernel density
estimator
are provably sub-optimal and this gap
actually increases with dimension
so we we ended up showing that certain
gans gans constructed in a in a
particular way are actually minimax
optimal under all of these settings
so since i only have 10 minutes i will
only talk about the
the generalization of the non-parametric
density estimation framework and the
fact that we were able to prove that
cans are minimax optimal
um so again is nothing but this
adversarial game of two networks a
generator and discriminator network so
the discriminator network takes in two
sets of samples the the real samples and
the ones generated by the generator and
it computes this
maximum expected discrepancy between
these two sets
and then you can think of the gan
estimate as
choosing a distribution among those that
the generator can represent such that
this
maximum discrepancy is as small as
possible so you can think of this as
simply a gan estimate for the true
distribution
and then so
you can see that
this can be thought of the discriminator
induced max discrepancy can just be
thought of as a metric
on the space of probability
distributions
and
so these are usually called integral
probability
metrics so in our work um oh a good
example of this is um for different
choices of f of d
you can actually get different metrics
here and one like classical example is
the wellstein metric which if you assume
that the the set of discriminator
functions is one lipschitz then you kind
of get um the weirdest time distance out
of this so here is a
small example of this so if you have two
singular distributions
uh in orange and blue then the green
functions are the one lipschitz
functions that maximize um this
discriminator loss and give you the
valentine distance between these two
distributions
so we chose to study this problem under
bess of ibm so all that means is that we
assume that these
discriminator function classes are just
specific spaces and i will talk about
that in in just a minute and one of the
main reasons that we did this is because
these
spaces are really general and if you
choose different probability spaces
different best of spaces then you get
different metrics um
from this
from this
example so you can you can pick fd to be
one lipschitz and you get the vastly
metric if you choose it to be the set of
um different sets then you get all these
other total variation metric kolmogorov
smyrna metrics and so on so best of
spaces are just two parametric family of
function spaces so you can just think of
this as a way of measuring the
smoothness
of your classes of functions
so s here is the measure is the
in short the number of derivatives that
it has and the boundedness of these
derivatives in the lp norm
so all you need to remember is that a
best of space is just a space of smooth
functions and we
have
different
you can measure different smoothness by
different values of its parameters
so a good example again of this is that
when you pick s to be one so you have
one derivative and you're measuring an
infinity norm you get the lipschitz
familiar functions
so now if i wanted to
estimate a distribution that was as
smooth so lived in some bus of space
under a particular bus of ipm
ideally what i would want to do is
optimize this ideal empirical risk right
over
the set of
the set of best of distributions over
this
bus of ipm
but again this is these two spaces are
infinite dimensional and i can't really
do this optimization
and so what we used in our work was the
fact that
you can use the regular neural networks
so fully connected networks to
approximate vessel spaces really well
and so what we do is that we plug in
these networks
for these two infinite dimensional
function spaces
um so you get something like if i have
i can construct neural networks of size
of depth login and other parameters only
polynomial n and replace them here and
then construct the scan estimate over
this generator and
discriminator and so we were able to
show that such a gan estimate is minimax
rate optimal
and it outperforms classical linear
estimators such as the kernel density
estimate
um and it is also
robust under contamination so all this
means is that if some epsilon proportion
of your data came from some other
density that you don't know and not from
the true density you can still show that
this framework works and is um
is class statistically rate optimal
so the biggest caveat here which is why
i'm here at this program is that we
assume that you can
compute the global optima of this min
max optimization which of course is
is very challenging
so um and also that you have these very
structured neural networks that you can
plug in
to get these rates of convergence
so
what i would like to learn this semester
is how can we relax these assumptions
what are the algorithms that can give
you convergence to global equilibria and
even if not
can we find points
that may not be global equilibria or any
or any such
points but still have good
generalization or will converge at the
same statistical rate
um the other big question here that is
not that relevant to this
this semester's work is how can we
escape this course of dimensionality
what are the right assumptions on the on
the data so that we can get away with
not having exponentially many samples so
exponential in in the dimension
and this other thing that is super
interesting is that what happens if we
consider very weak losses
so functions so suppose that i only
consider discriminators
that have functions that are computable
in polynomial time so polynomial in the
dimension
then can we say something um
then what can we say about the
convergence rate what can we say about
computing um the global equilibria
and that's it thank you for listening
i
yes you can
i'm sorry can you repeat that i couldn't
kill you so for your mini-map of the
whole test
did
log in the number of samples
[Music]
thank all the speakers from one
join us at the reception just outside